[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en sommes-nous derniers soubresauts du
drame algérien à oran où le calme s'est
rétabli après les dernières
manifestations dramatique de la semaine
passée les forces de l'ordre se sont mis
en devoir de passer au crible la ville
quartier par quartier les perquisitions
systématiques pratiqué par les gendarmes
et les crs qui avait déjà permis
l'arrestation de l'ex général jouhaud le
second de salles en ont fait découvrir
différents dépôts d'armes dont certains
étaient d'importance celui ci par
exemple qui comprenait sans fusil de
guerre et 10 mitrailleuse avec leur
canon de rechange
[Musique]
alger les années en militaires étaient
rendus aux douze soldats et gendarmes
tués par un commando à l eau début de la
révolte de bab el-oued le général
ailleret est allé s'incliner devant ces
victimes du doigt
l'abbé louette se réveillaient lentement
de sa torpeur après un blocus de cinq
jours les fouilles avaient amené plus de
3000 arrestations
mais aux traces laissées par le combat
sont venus depuis s'ajouter d'autres
ruines l'immeuble du mauritanien où
étaient installés les services d'air
france a été endommagé par une explosion
massive
[Musique]
dans les rues les tristes vestiges du
combat sont encore en place comme un
douloureux rappel est une leçon tragique
mais il y a à nouveau de la vie leur de
l'apaisement arrive-t-elle enfin
l'heure de l'apaisement avec leur de
l'espérance une espérance que chaque
français va sans doute fixé avec le
bulletin qu'il déposera dans l'urne du
référendum
[Musique]
éteindre l'énorme fuite de gaz qui brûle
dans le désert de gassies twill est un
travail d'hercule il fallait entre
autres à porter de touggourt les
soixante mille tonnes de baryte qui
seront déversés au moment où la flamme
sera soufflée par explosion
ce transport exceptionnel a pu être
menée à bien grâce au cargö du désert
que sont les camions géante et sans dont
les 700 chevaux et les roues
impressionnante se joue des difficultés
du terrain insensible qu'ils sont à tous
les pièges des sables à chaque navette
une bagatelle de 400 km à travers les
dunes les camions t100 ont amené à pied
d'oeuvre chacun 55 tonnes de bari
moyennant quoi l'heure approche où l'
incendie de gassi touil sera jugulée
[Musique]
un article porte de l'étang de berre les
automobilistes sont aujourd'hui
reconnaissant à la technique moderne qui
a lancé le nouveau pont mobile à
commande automatique de la jonquère la
circulation stoppé il ne faudra plus en
effet que 30 secondes un ouvrage pour
s'ouvrir de sa cabine à écran de
télévision l'opérateur n'a même pas
acheter un oeil sur le pont lui-même
l'important trafic de pétroliers vers
l'étang de berre zone en plein
épanouissement y trouve les mêmes
avantages de rapidité que la circulation
routière entre marseille et arles
autrefois stopper une demi heure à
chaque manoeuvre du vieux pots et puis
le nouveau pont enlève un record qui
n'est pas sans mérite il est sans doute
le plus élégant d'europe
[Musique]
en inaugurant la plus belle et la plus
complète exposition de l'art mexicain
que paris ait jamais vu monsieur andré
malraux a ouvert plus grande aux yeux
sur cette extraordinaire civilisation
aztèque dont les pyramides et les
sculptures nous remplissent toujours des
tonnes ce qu'il faut de préférence noter
dans cette réunion de quelques 3000
pièces c'est surtout peut-être ces
figures féminines d'une aisance et d'un
délicat maniérisme comparable aux
figures crétoise pour certaines d'une
humanité hautaine et religieuses pour
d'autres mais qui tout nous donne un
aspect jusqu'ici mal entrevues des
civilisations qui se succédèrent dans
l'ancien mexique
chose assez étrange ces visages dont on
a trop souvent vu que le tragique ça
fait sourire et même ce sourire sur ces
visages de pierre suite aller jusqu'au
rire avant ou en même temps peut-être qu
entrer dans le coeur de ses peuples
le féroce visage de la main
le monde artistique célèbre cette année
un compositeur français et paris n'a pas
manqué de lui rendre hommage darius
milhaud pour son 70e anniversaire vient
de diriger 4 de césaire ses 70 ans on
peut dire que darius milhaud les à
consacrer entièrement à la musique
puisque si on en croit sa vocation date
de l'âge de 3 ans entre sa femme et son
fils il n'hésite pas à avouer qu'il est
heureux qu'il l'a toujours été
et les souvenirs qu'ils remuent en
atteignant ses 70 ans sont des souvenirs
heureux ce sont ceux de 1911 à aix en
provence entre ses parents qui avaient
tout fait pour aider sa vocation précoce
ceux d'une distribution des prix au
brésil en 1910 est ce encore d'une fête
foraine en 1919 1920 c'était le groupe
des six adecco rick poulain que naguère
germaine tailleferre satie sans oublier
le septième perpétuelle manager
agitateurs des arts jean cocteau
la fête foraine était toujours au goût
du jour
[Musique]
1948 le retrouve aux côtés d'andré
maurois et fernand léger
1952 les six se sont retrouvés plus un
il retrouve une guerre
est aussi un grand inspirateur paul
claudel puis stravinsky mes 70 ans dit
il ne sont pas différents de mes 50 mais
ce qui me reste raccourci
[Musique]
cap et chapeau melon c'est ainsi que
daniel hechter couturier le 23 sans voix
les lycéennes aujourd'hui d'une
collection insolite qu'il a présentée
dans la rue en compagnie d'une consoeur
martin grandval qui elle habille les
anneaux on retiendra qu'à 16 ans le pull
à col roulé ne sera plus incompatibles
avec le deux pièces classiques
mais à la vérité les collégiennes n'ont
pas attendu que la mode leur arrive tout
près elles ont déjà fait elles mêmes
leurs moeurs
il suffit pour s'en rendre compte
d'assister à une sortie d'un lycée
parisien à hassine comme elle vise ou un
molière
de 13 à 17 ans on a des idées qui ne
sont pas celles de la grande soeur et on
les exprime pour commencer on a emprunté
les bretelles de papa unis vous rêviez
en élastique en cuir ou en tissu elles
ont éliminé les ceintures
du grenier on a sorti une ancienne
trousses de médecins de campagne pour en
faire un sac
les bottes plus haute se portant d'un
orné d'une chaîne concurrente avec les
chaussures plates
les jupes sont volontiers cours la
grande folie les chaussettes emprunté
aux frères a sorti des chaussures
cyclistes
et bien sûr on ne lésine pas sur les
bijoux les colliers sont faits d'une
quantité de chaînes très fine plus en
porte deux rangs plus c'est beau
les coiffures gonflante ont disparu la
vague eto'o ne poser comme des papillons
sur le sommet du crâne telle est la
nouvelle élégance des moins de 17 ans
qui fait fureur ont sans doute avec ces
tendances générales et variations de
détails c'est ainsi qu'aux chaînes
collier s'ajoutent volontiers en sautoir
la montre et l'alliance de grand mère
reste que le sac sacoche le gros
bracelets au bras le pantalon type marin
qu'on appelle du reste la marine est les
bottes les chaussettes les chaussures
cyclistes et jupe à bretelles
constituent les éléments clés d'une note
qui ne suis pas à la mode mais dont les
créateurs de mode devront finalement
tenir compte c'est la revanche des moins
de 16 ans
[Applaudissements]
chaque année à la même époque de tous
les coins de grande bretagne par
dizaines de milliers les britanniques
viennent à inscrire pour assister au
massacre on appelle cela pudiquement le
grand national de liverpool par pure
hypocrisie de fait il s'agit de la plus
belle hécatombe qui se puisse voir sur
un champ de plus à chaque des jockeys ou
chevaux il ans disparaît toujours
quelques-uns seuls le cheval freddy
somme semble se jouer de tous les
obstacles
[Musique]
tous sauf cette petite faute lui coûte
la victoire il va disparaître
successivement dépassé par quatre
adversaires
car aussi bizarre qu'il y paraisse après
tant de chute il reste encore assez de
chevaux pour que ferait descendre
termine à la cinquième place
et c'est finalement qu'il mord qui
remporte cette année le grand national
de liverpool
[Musique]
c'est sans grande passion que se sont
déroulées les demi finales de la coupe
de france de football le match vedette
la rencontre angers saint-etienne au
parc des princes à paris les angevins
jouent en blanc comme le real madrid
mais la comparaison s'arrête là de fait
ce match ne va durer qu'une mi temps au
cours de laquelle les stéphanois
dominent leurs adversaires par des
actions plus ample et mieux souder et
surtout à saint-etienne en tirent
souvent tendues et pas toujours
efficaces mais cela finit par être payés
et puis il suffit parfois d'un seul but
pour gagner un match c'est exactement le
cas des stéphanois qui jouera donc la
finale
aller nancy c'est en quelque sorte un
symbole qui a porté chance au joueur
nancéen eux aussi en maillot blanc ils y
sont allés sans trop de conviction mais
avec assez d'astuces pour battre le
football club de metz un peu malchanceux
il est prêt et je dois remet ça au
souvent dominé leurs adversaires au
cours de la partie mais les efforts
platonique en football ne paie pas à
preuve c'est nancy qui gagne par 1 but à
0 et qui jouera la finale contre
saint-etienne
[Musique]